ELIZABETH CHOE: So hi,
I'm Elizabeth Choe.
By day, I run the
MIT K-12 videos
program in the Office of
Digital Learning at MIT.
And I was the lead
instructor/creator 20.219.
JOSHUA GUNN: Hi,
I'm Joshua Gunn,
and I'm the co-founder of
Planet Nutshell a Cambridge,
Massachusetts, based
animation studio.
And my role in the
course was simply
to do a workshop
on storyboarding,
as well as a little
instruction on animation
in the context of producing
educational media.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: My
name is George Zaidan
I am a freelance science video
host and writer and producer.
And for 20.219 I did a workshop
on writing and hosting.
CHRIS BOEBEL: I'm Chris Boebel.
I'm media development director
for MIT's Office of Digital
Learning and for the course I
was basically a guest lecturer.
I came in for a day or two to
talk about visual storytelling.
ELIZABETH CHOE: So the way
this class stated, I would say,
is that George
and I were working
on Science Out Loud, which is
this educational web series
that's hosted by MIT students.
And it sort of noticed that
there was this big need
to help students not only know
how to articulate themselves
on camera-- articulate
well on camera--
but just understand
digital media in general.
And that's a conversation
that Chris and I
have had since I was your
student in undergrad basically.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Not
that many years ago.
ELIZABETH CHOE: So,
actually not really.
Yeah, but with Science Out
Loud we would do these,
like, crash courses on scripting
and writing these short videos,
but at the end of the day like
we would still intervene quite
a bit to make the videos good.
And at the end of
the day, the priority
was on making a great
video, and not necessarily
on the students'
learning experience.
So, I mean, this
was a space for them
to develop these skills
sort of lower states,
and not have to
worry about creating
something that was going to
be on a web series at the end.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: The class was
supposed to be lower stakes.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Because
we had-- Science Out Loud
was a lot of pressure.
We were shooting long days.
If they felt like they
didn't get to take right,
they were nervous.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Or,
if the script just
wasn't good by the time we had
to shoot, we would just fix it.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And one of
things you and I've talked
about a ton over the
last couple of years
is that tension between creating
a consistently good product
and teaching.
Because if you're in a
teaching environment,
you're going to fail over
and over and over again,
which does not lead to a
particularly, consistently good
product, which is
what you're going
for with Science Out Loud.
So this class is
kind of a way, I
think, to find a space in
between where you can actually
have a little bit of a chance
to experiment and learn by doing
and fail, bluntly.
But also not actually
impact your show, which
needs to be consistently good.
JOSHUA GUNN: Was
there any desire
to sort to create an
awareness for students
of other sort of creative
opportunities outside
of the science and math,
or their current studies?
I mean, I think it's a really
interesting way this course is
sort of offered to students
who are engaged in stuff that's
really quite different.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I mean,
interesting because MIT
has this communication
requirement,
but it's not really taken
seriously by students,
because it's like, I need to
take a class where I'm required
to write 20 pages of paper.
And you and I were
talking about one
at the bioengineering
communication fellows,
and he said something like, I'm
doing this program because I
don't see a difference
between science and science
communication.
But I think like that
was inadvertently
was what this class is about.
Because it's not really about
how to host a science show,
or how to write a
five minute script.
I don't care if they never
make a five minute video again,
but hopefully the skills that
they learned and picked up
were things that
they need to have,
regardless of what
they end up going to.
Just the ability to articulate
passionately and clearly
some very technical
topics is not something
you get trained
on enough at MIT.
CHRIS BOEBEL: I think I
think the MIT communication
requirement is an
interesting situation, too,
because it is all focused on
writing, and writing papers,
not even just writing
scripts, writing papers.
And, for instance,
the course that I
teach that you
took, we initially
had trouble getting it listed
as fulfilling the communication
requirement, even though
students consistently said,
well this is all this course
is about, communication.
Because the writing requirement
was just a little bit
shy of the 20 page, or
whatever it is, requirement.
So there's a whole other
kind of communication,
which is, as you say,
clear conceptualization,
visualization,
organization, which
is related to
writing, and writing
kind of traditional
papers, but it's in 2015.
It's not just writing
journal papers,
or kind of really more
traditional pieces of text.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Actually,
before I put the class together,
the first thing I did was just
survey all of the medial making
classes on campus.
So anything related
to video production
or like script production.
And there are actually a
lot of classes on campus
that are about how do you
edit, how do you produce video?
But there wasn't one on
really hosting, actually.
And being on camera, and
being comfortable talking
in front of people
was something that
we found to be very
important through Science
Out Loud and something
that most students were
the most comfortable
with, would you say?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah I
mean they didn't even
know they were
uncomfortable with it.
They'd just be like, oh yeah,
no problem, I'll just talk,
and then they get in front of
a camera and it's like Jack
Donaghy in that
episode of 30 Rock,
where he can't-- you know.
You don't understand why
your body doesn't quite
work the way you thought it was,
or your voice is a little too
high and you get nervous,
and then you screw up,
and then you screw up again.
And then if they
get and then they
realize how hard it actually is
to stand in front of a camera
and say things.
So yeah.
ELIZABETH CHOE: It's
not just about standing
in front of a camera, though.
JOSHUA GUNN: Any
audience, right?
ELIZABETH CHOE: I
feel like I wanted
them to learn to be
self aware of who they
were as a presenter, you know.
Like, we weren't trying to
make them become a persona.
Like we called it becoming
the next Bill Nye,
but it really wasn't.
That was like the
first thing I talked
about was that
we're not actually
turning you into Bill Nye.
That wherever you go,
whether it's a job interview,
or you're giving a Ted Talk or
formal presentation, I mean,
you need all these
skills and you
can't assume some sort
of platonic personality
When you do these things.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: It's not acting,
it's just being themselves.
ELIZABETH CHOE: But
just a clear, polished,
version of yourself.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Kind of close
to what the real thing is,
but maybe not
entirely there yet.
JOSHUA GUNN: Awareness
of an audience.